له حفيد هتلر? بكين ايضا تخطط
لشيء ما مع المانيا هنا باسم
يعلنون الحر ضد المجنون. الاحداث
والتطورات. فعلتها المغرب واغضبت
اجواء عدة مطارات اثر خروج صاروخ
صيني عن السيطرة. الصواريخ
سيادة البلدين. ليضع امريكا في
موقف محرج. بينما اغلقت اسبانيا
اخرى. والحال ان روسيا تبحث عن
اهداف جديدة في دول اخرى غير فمن
الاكبر ام الدخول في حرب ضد
روسيا؟ ومن حرب اوكرانيا الى حرب
تصعيد في الاثناء وصفت كوريا
الشمالية القرارات الامريكية
ثمانية عشر جرام ثمنه يصل الى
مئة وخمسة وتسعين الف دولار. فهل
لمقايضة بين دعم ايران لروسيا
وحصول طهران على مساعدة بالنووي
يحمل الدبور الاسود كلمة السر?
الصين مع حليف جديد. لا وقت
للمقاومة الفلسطينية وسط قطاع
غزة. النفط جعلت رئيس تشيلي يصل
التحتية. اما على صعيد التهديدات
هنا سويسرا تمنع المانيا من
الولايات المتحدة وجارتها
الجنوبية تمديد المناورات الجوية
لهذه الضغوط ولن تقدم اي تنازلات
لموسكو وقال ان اكبر خطأ لكييف
كل العرب والمسلمين. نعم. الرباط
تفتتح اول كنيسة يهودي بالعالم
تتحدثون يا هؤلاء رئيس وزراء
باكستان السابق عمران خان يتعافى
الوقت للترحيب بفنلندا والسويد
كعضوين في الناتو هكذا قالها
جهة اخرى وخوفا من مخطط روسي.
بولندا تضع اسلاكا شائكة على طول
يانج نحو ثمانين قذيفة مدفعية
على منطقة حدودية بحرية خلال
الخارجية الروسية الى وقف
الاستفزازات وبدورها هنا
وثمانون طائرة لكوريا الشمالية
تغيرت الخطة اليوم واطلقت بيونج
وبين هذا وذاك يظهر الرئيس
الاوكراني مصرحا ان هناك دولا لا
تدفع اوكرانيا نحو تسوية مع
روسيا واكد ان بلاده لن تستسلم
الانفتاح الاقتصادي وتوسيع شبكات
التجارة الدولية. لكن المستشار
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ميدفيديف
قائلا. لدينا اسلحة مختلفة قادرة
سيختارون بينما قالت رئيسة مجلس
الاتحاد الروسي فالنسينا
استنفار في شبه الجزيرة الكورية
فالشمالية تواصل اطلاق الصواريخ
الفين واربعة وعشرين. ودعت
الحكومات الى التحرك الفوري.
المتظاهرين وحمايتهم في البلاد
وطهران ترد يا سيد بايدن توقف عن
الانتقادات الاوروبية والامريكية
الواسعة لزيارته. فما الذي يخطط
بغبائها. لكن رئيس وزراء
بريطانيا ونظيره البولندي يقولان
انها لم تنشئ نظاما امنيا لمدة
ثلاثين عاما. فهل هذا الخطأ
وصفها بالحرب العدوانية ضد
اوكرانيا. ياتي الرد من نائب
ومجموعة السبع تتعهد بدعم
اوكرانيا ظل تضرر بنيتها
تعبئتهم بالفعل الى ثلاثمائة
وثمانية عشر الفا وهذا عدد كبير
شبه جزيرة القرم ليخرج نائب
بريطاني ويهاجم ليزيتراس مؤكدا
بحسب سي ان ان. ومن الحروب
النووية الى اعشاش الدبابير
اثناء مداهمة وكر مخدرات في
بيروت. فهيا لك من مخادعة ايتها
القادم. حيث اعلنت موسكو انها
سلمت السفيرة البريطانية لديها
الحدود بينها وبين جيب
كالينجراد. اهداف روسيا تزداد
وتتوسع يا سادة. فماذا يريد
بوتين? بريطانيا قد تكون هدف
الشرطة البيروفية. حرب روسيا
تشتد في مناطق اوكرانية وتخفت في
الاصبع يغير مسار المعارك
الميدانية في اوكرانيا سلاح وزنه
الحربي. وكما يطلق عليه الدبور
الاسود هو سلاح خفي بحجم عقلة
العربي واسمه بيت الله داخل حرم
جامعة محمد السادس عن اي بيت لله
الى قصره على الدراجة الهوائية.
رجال شرطة يتنكرون بزي مارفل
تحرك نووي ضدنا سوف يجعلنا
ننهيكم وبايدن يتعهد بتحرير
ننهيكم وبعد ان حلقت مائة
فيلم بعد محاولة اغتياله. ووزير
الداخلية الباكستاني يدعو حزب
المشتركة بينهما ووصفته بالخطير
والخاطئ لترد واشنطن قائلة اي
مواجهة وابل من التجارب
الصاروخية من قبل بيونغيانغ فهل
والطلعات الجوية والجنوبية تنشر
عشرات من طائرات الشبح حسبا لاي
ينبغي ان تتدخل فيه الولايات
المتحدة ويجب عليها ان تحترم
خان لمراجعة ترتيبات حمايته.
بايدن يتعهد بتحرير ايران ودعم
والكورية الجنوبية بغير المسئولة
كما انتقدت بيونج يانج قرار
لدينا اسلحة مختلفة قادرة على
ارسال اعداء روسيا الى الجحيم
الصينية دائما ما تفقد اعصابها
ليفقد السيطرة عليها. هل تذكرون
ليلة واحدة فيما تعهد وزيرا دفاع
سيول وواشنطن ابداء العزم في
مكهربة والحرب الكورية على بعد
قرار من هذا الطرف او ذاك.
الصاروخ الصيني التائه? استنفار
كوري. التوتر على اشده والاجواء
التقدم لتعلنها اوروبا? الصين
تستعد لمرحلة جديدة تعزز فيها
الخارجية الصينية التعاون
الموجود بين الصين والمانيا لا
سياستها الخارجية ويخرج الصيني
قائلا سنعمل على تعزيز منصات
وعلى الارض تصاعدت المعارك في
محيط مدينة خرسون جنوب اوكرانيا
الالماني يتحدى المواقف الغربية
المعارضة ويزور الصين. رغم
على ارسال كل الاعداء الى
الجحيم. لكن هذه ليست مهمتنا.
اوكرانيا وبلهجتها الحادة تعلن
عن احتجاجها. ومن حرب التهديدات
ارسال ذخيرة سويسرية الصنع مضادة
للطائرات الى اوكرانيا بينما دعت
بصوت واحد نقول للرئيس الروسي ان
سياسة التخويف لن تجدي نفعا. حان
تصرفاتك المنافقة. الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يشن غارات على موقع
الى حرب الاستخبارات. هنا
معلومات لاستخبارات امريكية تشير
الامين العام لحلف الناتو ينس
تولتنبرغ. مضيفا ان السويد
ادلة على تورط لندن في الهجمات
الاخيرة على الاسطول الروسي في
وفنلندا ملتزمتان بالعمل مع
تركيا لمعالجة مخاوفها الامنية
انها كشفت تورط بلاده في تفجير
خط النورزستريم ليقول لقد فضحتنا
مطالبا الرئيس الصيني باستخدام
نفوذه للضغط على روسيا لوقف ما
تثير الرعب في اسبانيا امريكا
البنتاجون لكوريا الشمالية. اي
اخرى او قد تكون حرب وليست حربا
واحدة. سقوط صواريخ روسية على
على شروط تحديد سقف اسعار النفط
الروسي. ليرد الرئيس فلاديمير
انه ينبغي ابعاد المدني
المتواجدين في خرسون ليعلن بعدها
بوتين ان روسيا لن تقوم بتصدير
اي شيء للخارج اذا كان ذلك
زعيم الكرملين ان تدفق المتطوعين
الراغبين في الالتحاق بالقوات
اوكرانيا? سلاح خفي صغير يغير
مسار معارك اوكرانيا? والصين
للضغط الغربي وبولندا ومولدوفا
في حيرة. من سيكون التالي بعد
في ظل غموض حول مصير المنطقة
الاستراتيجية هناك يؤكد بوتين
بلدة حدودية في مولدوفا في
سيناريو يتوقع منه حرب جديدة من
للراحة. اصحاب العيون الضيقة لا
يتوقفون. لا يكلون ولا يملون من
جدا من الناس بحسب قوله ليخرج
المستشار الالماني وراتشولز
اوروبا تواجه خطر نفاذ الغاز
خلال شتاء الفين وثلاثة وعشرين
الاملاءات من احد. لتخرج وكالة
الطاقة الدولية محذرة من ان
المسلحة لروسيا الاتحادية لا
يتراجع وقد وصل عدد الذين تمت
مادفينكو ان روسيا لا تعتبر
نفسها عدوا للغرب لكنها لا تقبل
يتعارض مع مصالحها الخاصة
والخيار للغرب. فما الذي
ايران والمغرب يستفز العرب
والمسلمين. فما الذي جرى? حرب
اين ستنتهي? وكيف سيكون الحال
عندها تعلنها? دول الغرب اتفقت
وتتهمها بالخيانة. بريطانيا
تتورط في مواجهة حتمية مع روسيا.
سيعود اثرها عليهم كسابقاتها
الرد حاسما وسريعا من بوتين
سويسرا توقف الالمان عن هذه
الخطوة العسكرية اوكرانيا
روسيا والغرب. الحرب تمضي ويحاول
العالم ايقافها لكن لا احد يعلم
فما الذي سيفعله الانجليز?
اوروبا في خطر. وزينسكي يتعرض
والمستشار الالماني يستنجد
بالصين والسبب موسكو بينما
وفي وقت قياسي. عاصفة عقوبات
جديدة صوب روسيا من اوروبا فهل
التالي ايها الروس؟